♪ ♪
>> Tucker: JOE BIDEN’S
HANDLERS HAVE CLAIMED AGAIN AND
AGAIN THAT HE WILL STICK WITH
THE PRESIDENTIAL DEBATES AND
FACE-OFF AGAINST THE INCUMBENT
THREE TIMES BEFORE THE ELECTION,
STARTING NEXT MONTH.
THEY CLAIMED THAT AS RECENTLY AS
TODAY.
OF COURSE, THAT PROMISE IS BEING
TAKEN AS A THREAT BY DEMOCRATIC
OPERATIVES AROUND BIDEN.
THEY KNOW THE CANDIDATES POLL
NUMBERS DEPEND ENTIRELY ON
VOTERS BEING UNABLE TO SEE OR
HEAR HIM SPEAK.
IF BIDEN ISN’T ALLOWED TO TALK
IN PUBLIC, HE WILL RUIN
EVERYTHING.
THAT IS WHY THE SUM OF
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" RAN A PIECE
SAYING THAT BIDEN SHOULDN’T
DEBATE UNLESS TRUMP
RELEASES HIS TAX RETURNS.
IT WAS AN OBVIOUS PLOY, WE NOTED
THAT AT THE TIME BUT AT LEAST
TOM FRIEDMAN TRIED TO PRETEND HE
WAS TAKING A PRINCIPLED STAND.
IT WAS ABOUT FAIRNESS.
NOTHING TO DO WITH JOE BIDEN’S
INABILITY TO THINK CLEARLY.
JUST FAIRNESS.
BUT LEAVE IT TO FORMER
BILL CLINTON PRESS SECRETARY,
THE DUMBEST PERSON EVER TO HOLD
THAT JOB, TO SHADOW THE FACADE.
IN A COLUMN LAST WEEK TITLED
"JOE BIDEN COULD STILL LOSE THIS
ELECTION," HE SPELLED OUT HIS
PRESCRIPTION DIRECTLY TO BIDEN.
HE USED BIRTH EVEN BIDEN COULD
UNDERSTAND.
DR. SEUSS LEVEL STUFF.
WHATEVER YOU DO COME HE WROTE TO
JOE BIDEN, DON’T DEBATE A
TRUMP."
GOT THAT?
AS IF YOU NEED TO SPELL OUT THE
CONTEMPT FOR VOTERS A LITTLE
MORE CLEARLY, LOCKHART WARNED
THAT A TRUMP CAN’T FOLLOW THE
RULES OR THE TRUTH.
THAT’S COMING FOR THE FLACK FROM
THE PRESIDENT WHO WAS IMPEACHED
FOR LYING.
COMING FROM A MAN WHO POSTED A
MADE UP CONVERSATION BETWEEN
REPUBLICAN SENATORS BACK IN
JANUARY.
IRONY OF COURSE, HE’S DEAD.
THE PALLBEARER IS JOE LOCKE
HARD.
BUT HARDLY ALONE.
OPERATIVES HAVE RECEIVED THEIR
MARCHING ORDERS.
BILL KRISTOL, THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTISAN FIGURE, HE SHOULDN’T
DEBATE.
THE PUBLIC KNOWS MORE THAN IT
ALREADY DOES.
TOO MUCH INFORMATION COULD BE
BAD FOR OUR PLANS TO TAKE POWER.
SHUT IT DOWN."
TELLS YOU EVERYTHING.
SPEAKING OF THE ABILITY TO
FREELY DISSEMINATE INFORMATION,
77% OF REPUBLICANS POLLED SAID
THEY WERE AFRAID TO EXPRESS
THEIR OPINIONS PUBLICLY.
THEY KNOW THAT EXPRESSING RIGHT
OF CENTER VIEWS COULD GET THEM
FIRED, SO WHAT IS THE
CONSERVATIVE ESTABLISHMENT FROM